oi qual é o seu medo
é o que te faz suar frio de dizer que
libra ou te paralisa diante de uma
situação tem gente que tem medo de
altura medo da morte o medo de ser
abandonada que ser rejeitado medo de
barata mas esses medos a gente conhece
muito bem e a gente passa a vida se
preparando para não travar diante deles
mas existe um medo que a gente fala
pouco um medo que talvez seja mais
perigoso porque a gente não conhece bem
eu me refiro ao medo do sucesso é um
medo estranho mas a gente vai entender
isso juntos eu quero começar dando
é um exemplo e uma pergunta como vocês
acham que eu me sentia aos vinte e
poucos anos tendo acabado de me casar
com um homem porque eu era apaixonada
recém chegada no rio de janeiro e já
despontando com matriz nas capas de
muitas revistas porque eu tava fazendo
novelas e minisséries que tava fazendo
muito sucesso no brasil todo tava sendo
aclamada pela crítica amada pelo público
tava vivendo um momento de comoção que
eu jamais sonhei viver
e aí
oi oi
[Música]
e aí zé trovão quando é calma aí
e se vocês imaginaram que nesse momento
eu me senti a pessoa mais afortunada do
mundo vocês é raro nesse período da
minha vida onde eu realmente tinha tudo
que eu poderia desejar para mim sentir
plenamente feliz a verdade é que em
muitos momentos eu me sentia
extremamente insegura feia e sem talento
mas como é que eu me sentia tão frágil
no momento de tanta glória eu comecei a
entender um pouco esse processo numa
conversa que eu tive anos atrás com uma
amiga ana vitória vieira monteiro e ela
disse que já tinha notado que na minha
carreira toda vez que eu tava no momento
de grande expansão de aumento do meu
brilho pessoal eu simplesmente sair de
cena desapareciam ia e aí ela disse que
eu tinha medo do sucesso na hora que ela
falou eu acreditei né falei como assim
medo do sucesso ninguém
o sucesso a gente ama o sucesso mas
quando eu já tava nesse caminho sem
volta de autoconhecimento eu resolvi
investigar e passei semanas passando
minha vida limpo de trás para frente de
frente para trás revendo tudo até chegar
à conclusão de que ela tava certa eu
tinha medo do sucesso agora veja bem uma
pessoa pode me fazer uma observação como
essa e eu acordar mas eu vou ter que ter
coragem para ser honesta comigo mesma e
reconhecer que fui eu que bloqueei meus
caminhos porque todo movimento de cura
vai depender só de mim e eu também sou a
única pessoa que tem acesso a verdade de
qual era o meu sentimento toda vez que
eu recebi um convite para realizações
maiores
oi iaiá o que é que você sente
entusiasmo ou medo
oi eu voltei naqueles momentos da minha
vida e pude sentir meu coração apertar
de medo cada vez que eu recebi um
convite para alçar voos mais altos como
um passarinho tá lá no alto do ninho e
precisa ser tirar pela primeira vez o
medo do sucesso a medo de crescer eu
preferia mil vezes está ali no meu
cantinho no meu quadradinho mesmo que
minha vida estivesse insatisfatória que
eu tivesse infeliz me sentindo frustrada
mas pelo menos naquele espaço eu
conhecia tudo muito bem eu te amo ilusão
de que eu tinha um controle o mundo lá
fora me fazer nenhum convites incríveis
eu dizia não eu percebi que a partir de
um determinado momento o sucesso ea
ficando tão volumoso que eu começava a
recusar os convites
e quer dizer que tudo que a gente sente
dentro se manifesta fora na nossa
realidade sim se eu preferia ficar na
minha zona de conforto universo me
obedecia seu internamente vibrava medo
dos desafios naturalmente as portas e um
se fechando e eu ficava muito satisfeita
com isso porque crescer dá trabalho é um
desafio que exige coragem abertura eu
precisava ter minha largado por dentro
primeiro eu vou explicar eu eu já cresci
com um artista filha de pai e mãe
artistas mas eu nunca imaginei que eu
fosse levar a minha arte para além da
cerca do quintal da casa que eu cresci
lá em salvador meu pai artista plástico
chico liberato minha mãe alba é poetisa
e roteirista e todo aniversário lá em
casa encontro de final de semana com a
a sua família a gente fazia logo o sarau
de poesia com música dança teatro e tudo
que é tipo de manifestação artística que
aparecia naquele momento então esse
espaço do quintal da minha casa foi
minha escola de arte foi no laboratório
e eu tive que destravar muita coisa até
consegui me expressar artisticamente de
uma forma confortável então em menos de
dois anos morando no rio de janeiro que
eu fui só para passar um réveillon e
acabei ficando universo me presenteou
com oportunidades para fazer parte de
trabalhos que fizeram muito sucesso no
brasil todo e foi um atrás do outro
primeiro foi tieta na globo aí nem tinha
acabado tieta me chamaram para fazer o
pantanal na extinta tv manchete depois
da minissérie o canto das sereias e
finalmente a história de ana raio e zé
trovão
e onde eu era a protagonista e fui
consagrada não só nas capitais como no
interior também eu e alguns atores
desses projetos eram os atores
iniciantes desconhecidos e de repente
não conseguia mais sair na rua era muito
amor na nossa direção isso dá medo sabe
quando você tá numa relação que tá tudo
dando muito certo você tá feliz e aí de
repente você começa a achar que uma
coisa vai dar errado e você resolve
terminar com a relação não aconteceu
nada de errado tá tudo bem tá tudo dando
certo mas você começa a alimentar uma
nuvenzinha de maus pressentimentos aí
alegria vai virando o medo que você só
bota a relação eu já fiz isso algumas
vezes então esse medo de se entregar
para o sucesso para felicidade também é
o medo de não conseguir sustentar essa
situação tão
o medo de fracassar e aí acreditando que
eu vou fracassar' e ontem tecido esse
fracasso e assim pelo menos onde você
pega de surpresa mais uma vez eu tenho a
ilusão de que eu tô controlando alguma
coisa eu trago esse exemplo aqui para
vocês para dizer que o sucesso que eu me
refiro não é o sucesso só que atores têm
quando fazem novela quando fazem cinema
o sucesso aqui é você sente bem sucedido
se sentir realizado nas suas relações
com a sua família com seu trabalho e
principalmente na sua relação com você
mesmo para você poder ser verdadeiro
porque o medo do sucesso ele não vem com
cara de medo ele vem disfarçado então eu
me dava desculpas muito plausíveis eu
dizia eu parei um pouco para descansar
eu parei para criar cavalo
a área para construir uma família veja
bem eu eu acho um luxo eu acho uma
benção uma pessoa poder parar para esses
momentos que são tão especiais tão
importantes na nossa vida mas eu parava
para descansar por meses parei para
criar cavalo por quatro anos no auge da
minha carreira recebendo convites
incríveis e dizendo não para todos eles
claro que depois de uns 2 anos eu
comecei a me sentir feliz e aí graças a
deus venha arte e me resgata de volta
sempre aparece alguém e com convite
muito bom e sem aceitar a minha recusa
então quando eu já tava de novo fazendo
trabalho e significativos no teatro na
tv e no cinema eu resolvi só isso dos
grandes centros e ir morar mais afastado
mas detalhe sem manter nenhum contato
com o mercado de
eu tinha conquistado quando a gente sabe
o valor de um caminho percorrido das
relações que a gente conquistou com
dedicação com sua com afeto a gente
entende que família e trabalho podem e
devem caminhar juntos uma coisa não
anula a outra eu voltei naqueles
momentos fui verdadeira comigo e vi que
aquilo tudo foi desculpa para justificar
a fuga outro disfarce do medo do sucesso
é a humildade na época que eu recebi
esses convites da vida e dizia não para
todos eles eu achava que era humilde que
se uma colega minha também não tava
brilhando muito tava apagada eu abafava
meu próprio brilho eu ficava ali
sufocando a minha luz para ela sentir
melhor
bom então
e como é que a gente pode se inspirar
com uma pessoa que sufoca a própria luz
eu pelo menos me sinto inspirada com
pessoas que brilham seu potencial máximo
meus modelos são pessoas que têm coragem
para ser feliz então eu acreditava que
eu tava sendo humilde mas isso não é
humildade se a vida universo deus como
você quiser chamar de data minha se
abrindo e você dá as costas para esse
caminho isso não é humildade é uma falsa
humildade na verdade isso é uma
arrogância uma ingratidão claro que tudo
que a vida nos dá é muito importante eu
recebo esses presentes e não uhu é como
uma fruta que cai do pé antes de
produzir alguma coisa aqui de colocar
seus dons a serviço do mundo o dom de
alimentar saborosamente uma pessoa
rodando de virar uma árvore uma
e lá na bahia a gente fala que essa
fruta que caia toda hora ela tá peca
e esse é o verdadeiro pecado tá aí sem
produzir nada sem colocar seus dons a
serviço do mundo a verdadeira humildade
é a gente brilhar nosso potencial máximo
então quando eu percebi que eu tava
sufocando meu brilho por medo da
exposição eu resolvi escrever um livro
colocar nele todas as minhas mentiras
arrancar todas as máscaras e publicar
para todo mundo ver
e o livro medo do sucesso foi escrito em
menos de 4 meses
o parecer que estava pronto dentro de
mim entalado na minha garganta eu
precisava confessar para me sentir livre
e teve momentos que o nível da exposição
da minha intimidade da fragilidade era
tão grande que eu precisava parar para
respirar me dava falta de ata mãe a era
identificação com a máscara que eu tava
arrancando e aí aos poucos eu fui
e destravando eu fui retirando essas
capas de proteção essa armadura e fui
descobrindo a minha fragilidade a minha
imperfeição a minha humanidade ea partir
desse passo que parece muito simples
muito fácil mas não é eu comecei
encontrar minha verdadeira força comecei
a me curar e a ressignificar o sucesso
então sucesso seja você uma médica um
professor uma dona de casa uma torre não
importa sucesso né você tá no centro das
atenções sendo bajulado não sucesso você
tem coragem de honrar os seus dons
divinos e colocá-los a serviço de um
propósito maior é você conseguir confiar
na vida no universo e dando um passo
depois do outro né
a dança e conectada com essa potência
maior que a gente recebe da própria vida
ou de deus a gente para de depender das
circunstâncias externas para se sentir
bem porque a gente já vai estar bem e
nesse estado de amor próprio onde a
gente está sendo guiado pelo coração a
gente também para de depender da atenção
e do amor do outro porque a gente
aprendeu esse absurdo de que o amor vem
de fora o amor é uma vivência é uma
experiência uma sensação interna é como
quando a gente gosta muito de uma comida
e a gente precisa comer para sentir o
gosto tem como a gente pedir para outra
pessoa comer a nossa comida comida que a
gente gosta para a gente sente o gosto
não
é nesse mundo de sentidos a gente tem
que experience are com amor é a mesma
coisa e para isso ele não precisa de
outra pessoa basta tá vivo acordar
respirar e se abrir para deixar esse
amor brotar de dentro
e esse é o verdadeiro sucesso então eu
precisei viver 53 anos para entender que
sucesso é humildade gratidão e coragem
para colocar meus dons a serviço de um
propósito maior eu espero que vocês
saibam receber o que a vida nos dá de
braços abertos e que vocês se permitam
brilhar no seu potencial máximo
colocando toda sua luz a serviço de todo
o seu amor na master a
e aí